-You mentioned your son.
He is graduating from 1st grade?
-1st grade tomorrow.
It's his little
graduation ceremony.
-What is a
graduation ceremony --
What are you expecting from
a 1st-grade graduation ceremony?
-I believe they will say,
"You are all now 2nd graders."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-And all of us will be crying
and saying, "Yes!
You did it!"
-Now, what is your son into
as a 7-year-old?
-Well, recently,
my son was on a playdate,
a very unusual playdate,
I thought.
I wasn't at the playdate,
'cause it was at the other --
They do this thing at my son's
school that he really loves.
If you're going to
someone else's house,
you can sign your child out,
and they go home with
the other nanny or parent,
which makes them feel
very independent.
And so he loves that.
-Of course.
-So, I had signed him out
to go to this playdate
with a few girlfriends that he's
very close with in his class.
And during the playdate, I
had received a video.
And the mom said,
"Oh, they're having so much fun.
They're doing a
little fashion show right now."
So, she sent me the video.
And the two girls in
the playdate come out
looking like
beautiful princesses.
And then my son
comes out wearing
a full princess dress, as well.
He used purple marker
to make eye shadow and contour.
And he gave his best walk
and then he went, "Fashion!"
And, so, I said,
"Where did you learn this?
Like, what was
your inspiration for this?"
And he said, "Oh, it's because
I watched 'RuPaul's Drag Race.'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fantastic.
-It's amazing.
-Yeah.
-And for a moment,
I questioned my parenting,
but then I said, "No.
This is amazing that,
first of all,
he picked up some good tips."
-Yes. Exactly.
-Second, I'm
proud that my son knows
"RuPaul's Drag Race"
and can, like, compete.
-Yeah. Exactly.
-I mean, he could
have flipped over a table,
like the New Jersey Housewives.
I might have been a
little more embarrassed
if he watched that with me.
-Exactly. There's some
decency to the way
they go about themselves
in "Drag Race," yeah.
So, congratulations on the
final season of "Kimmy Schmidt."
And this is, obviously,
your second show
that you've worked with
Tina Fey and Robert Carlock.
Is it true that Tina and the
writing staff will sometimes
write things with
no expectations that you,
as an actor,
will actually have to do them?
-Well, first, let me say it's
gonna be very, very bittersweet
for this show to end, because
my relationship with Tina Fey
is my most successful and
longest-lasting relationship
in my life.
-I mean, it's incredible.
Two shows and
two great characters.
-And I'm going to
miss it terribly,
and especially the wacky group
of players that we have,
with Titus and Ellie
and Carol Kane.
We are all very close,
and I'm going to miss the sort
of wacky fun that we have there.
But I have noticed, sometimes,
they put things in the script
that, because I take their
writing so seriously,
I just think is -- I'm expected
to do whatever they put there.
And there was an episode of
"30 Rock" where they wrote --
We were fighting over the
same guy, Liz Lemon and Jenna.
And it was supposed to be
like that movie thing
where you go "ahh"
and then put your arm around
your date, your supposed date.
So, they said,
"Well, Liz does it,
but then Jenna does it
with her leg."
And, so, we did the rehearsal,
and I did that.
I mean, I was like --
I can't do it here, 'cause...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...you'll be off the air.
-But I literally did it,
and she was like,
"We never expected that
you could do that."
We just wrote that as, like,
an imagery, like an idea.
-I was like, "Oh, I thought --
Like, I practiced at home."
-Exactly. You're like,
"I was the Dining Car, Ms. Fey!"
Thank you so much
for being here, Jane.